so let's talk about two very broad
categories of loans one is installment
loans and one is revolving loans or
revolving credit so if we're talking
about installment loans or installment
credit that's a situation where you're
borrowing one usually large amount of
money and then you're paying it back in
installments the most common examples of
this are a car loan your student debt
payment or a mortgage where you might
say borrow a hundred thousand dollars
and then you're paying it down over 10
15 30 years where you're paying usually
a fixed amount every year to pay down
how much you borrowed plus paying the
interest now the other end of the
spectrum or the other category I should
say is revolving credit or revolving
loans and the one most common to or most
familiar to most people is your credit
card you don't call that necessarily
revolving credit but that's what it is
what that means is there's some limit
that you can borrow that the credit card
issuer says all right I'll lend you up
to a thousand dollars that's your credit
card limit and you can use it as long as
you spend less than a thousand dollars
and then you can pay it down and then
you can use some more Etc et cetera so
let's say you have a thousand dollar
credit card limit and right now you have
not borrowed or you haven't used it at
all then you go out you spend fifty
dollars on clothing now you owe the
credit card company the issuer fifty
dollars and you could borrow an extra
950 from them because you've used fifty
dollars of that thousand dollars now you
could pay that down and I highly
recommend paying it down as quickly as
possible you could pay down that fifty
dollars and now you could borrow up to a
thousand dollars so that's why it's
called revolving you're constantly using
some of it and then paying some of it
back using some of it paying it
something some of it back other that's
the most common example in most people's
lives there's also things like personal
lines of credit that you might be able
to get from a bank sometimes they'll
lend you that based on the value that
you have in your house where you can
borrow money and then pay it back borrow
money and pay it back up to some type of
a limit so those are the two big
categories it's nice to have a little
category knowledge in your head about
how they might different how they might
be different one is usually one large
lump sum purchase that you're borrowing
money for and then you're paying it back
in usually fixed installments the other
is you have some kind of a credit limit
and you can borrow and pay back borrow
and pay back
um depending on on on what your needs
are in life